تواجه اداره اتهامات بالتخليل عمليه
التدريجيه عن مبدا الصين الواحده لصالح
استراتيجيه الدعم المباشر لتايوان
اعلن صراحه ان بلاده سترسل قوات امريكيه
للدفاع عن جزيره تايوان خطوات ثلاث تمريره
الكونجرس تشريعا يمولوا خطه دفاعيه
لتايبيه وفقا لصحيفه جورنال
مشروع قانون السياسه الدفاعيه السنوي لهذا
العام قيمته
858 مليار دولار اقره مجلس الشيوخ يضم
بنودا خاصه بتايوان هي الاكبر بتخصيص ما
يصل الى 10 مليارات دولار من التمويل ومنح
الاسلحه على مدار خمس سنوات ما يوفر وسيله
دعم اضافيه لنقل الاسلحه خلال المبيعات
المباشره ويزيد من انفاق واشنطن على
مخزونات الذخيره في منطقه المحيط الهادئ
من 200 مليون دولار الى 500 مليون دولار
سنويا حيث يمكن لتايوان ان تسحب منها اذا
لزم الامر كما يمنح مشروع القانون الرئيسي
سلطه سحب المخزونات الحاليه من الاسلحه
لنقلها مباشره
في حاله هجوم من ص او اعمال عدوانيه
[موسيقى]
مثلت اهم التحركات الامريكيه لاستغلال
ازمه تايوان لصالحها في مشاعل لاحياء
التحالفات اسيويه متعدده عسكريه وسياسيه
وتقنيه
لمواجهه الصعود الصينيه لكن الصين ردت
بشكل حازم اما عسكريا فتمثلت بمناورات حول
الجزيره هدفت من خلالها الى التاكيد على
قدرتها على فرض حصار بحريه وان واشنطن لن
تستطيع التدخل لمساعدتها او دعمها عسكريا
سياسيا كان موقف بكين واضحا بتحذير وجهه
وزير الدفاع الصنيفنج لنظيره الامريكيه
لايتنز من ان قضيه تايوان خط احمر يجب عدم
تجاوزه داخليا في تايوان اظهرت الانتخابات
البلديه الاخيره تراجع الدعم الشعبي
لتوجهات رئيسه
للصين روان حمزه العربيه